share your world invites you to learn
about different cultures through our
personal stories
in this episode we're celebrating
holidays from our cultural backgrounds
every culture has its own holiday
traditions
today we're sharing a few of our
favorites there's a holiday in the
armenian culture
called vartavar or vardavar depending on
if
you're an eastern armenian or western
army and dialect this usually happens in
july and basically it is the day where
everyone splashes each other with water
everyone's running into fountains
it is just like a country-wide water
fight
part of our goes back to the pagan times
and it is to worship the goddess osleek
which is the goddess of water love
fertility and
beauty and next summer i am definitely
hoping i can go to armenia and stay at
the armenia marriott
hotel yerevan and if i can be there
during vartavar during the water
fight of the year then that would be
perfect because i can just walk out of
my hotel
and there's the fountain and i can get
drenched and then just walk right back
into the hotel and carry on
my favorite holiday for sure is
christmas
and i think more so because i'm not
home like i'm i live in l.a and i'm not
in switzerland
so christmas is usually the time of the
year where i try to go home
what helps me even more to get into the
christmas spirit is
our christmas market in basel it's just
walking through the market you know you
you smell all the different smells from
the foods and the drinks and we
obviously have mulled wine
which i think is kind of known here or
it's starting to get to be known here
which is a hot wine with different
spices with cinnamon and you can throw
apple into it i used to go
every year as a child as a teen so it's
not it's not that it's
new every year it's always the same
usually the same people the same vendors
but it's still always magical it just is
like i absolutely love it
debbie will you pick fondue or rucklet
when you're at the market
oh my gosh i get this question a lot um
i think fondue so they're both um very
interactive with you know the people
that are sitting around the table you
chat you
talk you exchange the food that's on the
table that goes with it like potatoes or
corn or whatever your size that you like
it's a really good dinner so
i uh i can't wait to go back home and
and have a traditional swiss rock
light or fondue in my family i think the
holiday that we look
forward to the most is always
thanksgiving which is not
by any means a traditional nigerian
holiday
but we've definitely made it into our
own version of the holiday
for our thanksgiving spread we have your
typical
turkey and your ham and your stuffing
but we'll also throw in a lot of
traditional nigerian dishes so we'll
have jell-o rice which is a staple
in our food we'll have moi moi moi moy
is
black eyed peas that is blended with
different spices
like garlic tomato
a whole bunch of things and then it's
boiled into like
a bean round it's really good we'll have
foreign is
a spinach stew that is my favorite stew
typically eaten with
a fufu of some type whether it's pounded
yam
or amala you choose your fufu but
yeah it's a it's an american tradition
that we've made our own
my favorite holiday is cambodian new
year it happens
the weekend of april 13th around that
time
and it's a lot of family time and
there's a lot of culture time
there's a little gambling as well we
call it a clock cloak
where it's basically the sheet that has
different animals on it we have dice
where we put three dice in a bowl we
shake it
and people would put dollars on like the
chicken
or on the crab and the dice would come
out and if it has
a chicken or crab you get a dollar for
each of the things
jason do you bet on any particular
animal
like is one luckier than the other i
just love crab i think it's lucky
so i would definitely always try to bet
on crab
i'm glad we can uh virtually connect
because
sometimes it feels like you're just here
you know
and you can't travel and stuff but i i
honestly feel like i went to a new
locations
just by chatting with you so i like
traveled
in my chair i love that
it's definitely great to be able to like
connect sometimes we feel like we're
different people but
food brings people together we can feel
the connection over
our love for food that's true
i think we can all agree that we can't
wait to come back together
and travel when we're able we hope
you're excited to someday experience
these and other holiday traditions in
their home countries
[Music]
you